So here's the Python expression to compute that. We're multiplying
the speed of light times 100 cm in a meter, times
1 divided by 1 billion. One nanosecond is one billionth of
a second. You'll note that I can't have space in the
numbers. It's convenient when I write out the numbers to put
spaces in them, so we can see how big they are.
Python doesn't allow that, that looks like separate numbers if we
have spaces there that wouldn't be valid in the Python grammar.
So we can't have the spaces there, so when we run
this we get the result 29. That says it's about 29
centimeters that light travels in one nanosecond. This is a little
surprising that is an exact number, and it's an integer, and
the reason it's an integer is because of the way Python
does arithmetic. If all the numbers here are integers, Python will
truncate down to that integer. If we want a more accurate
result we should turn one of these numbers into a decimal number.
So now we've changed the one to 1.0, now we run it we get 29.979. Two, four,
five, eight, so almost 30 centimeters, which is a better answer than 29 was.